来喜欢的姐姐就扣
9块9块扣1扣1啊
来走过路过
不要错过了
9块扣个1
来这个灰色的
灰色的这个全有
有个黑点点
这个上面有一个黑点点
单层的啊
就这一个黑点
这个本来卖39的
卖39的这个有个黑点点
因为它是摆折的
它是摆折的
这个黑点点
我跟你说你穿在身上
是不怎么能看得到的
来腰围的话64
可以拉到90
臀围的话就很大了啊
臀围咱就不量了
裙长的话是85
裙长85
来这个裙子谁要
前一十块钱29
29扣个1
29谁要谁来扣个1
谁要
谁来扣个1
扣1扣1
来这个aimy他们家的啊
这个裙子吊牌价是1万
1万45的
两边有口袋腰上有抽绳
面料锯纸的aimy他们家的啊
这种面料你看薄的很很薄又软
又薄又软又丝滑
又丝滑啊
他写的是个l码
来腰围的话是64
可以拉到92
臀围不见啊
来裙长75
来这款谁要59
59 59扣个5
来喜欢的姐姐就说
59 59
谁要谁来扣个5
来这个花裙花裙
59扣个5
来喜欢的姐姐就扣啊
哎呦我的妈呀
明天中午吃的太撑了
吃了一碗拉面
来这个百折裙
卡其色的
咖色的应该是咖色
来这个是i k k a的
i k k a的这个百折裙
面料就像铜鞍丝醋酸
看看丝滑百折啊
小百折的
咱们来量一下
腰围62
可以拉伸到90
存为不限
寻常82
来这一款29扣0
谁要谁来扣个0
来喜欢的姐姐就扣
29扣个0
来这个格子裙
L码的
直筒的
人民19
誉旨77
区拥 ambassador4
轮码
门ELL
幕前面有一排扣
这个都是
抆周天窗
前面开剎
直筒裙
前面有装饰裤的
后面看到腰围
好看啊
来腰围的话是68
可以拉伸到86
68 86
来臀围
臀围的话是100
100 104
平常88
来这一款谁要谁来扣
29 29扣8
29 29
谁要谁来扣可把两边有斜插口袋啊
两边有斜插口袋的
来喜欢的姐姐就扣
29 29扣8扣8
扣8扣8
来姐妹们看一下这款MOSI
MOSI的啊
来腰是有弹力的
松紧性大啊
它是一个人棉尼龙锯纸的
MOSI MOSI S嘛
人棉76
尼龙21锯纸3%
来这一款
后面口袋上面有直插口袋
底边开扎啊
来这一款咱们来量一下
腰围62 78
腿围92 100
来裙长裙长83
来这个裙子谁要49 49扣个4
49扣个4包腿的啊
这种直身的显得人又瘦又高
他有黑的灰的和这个米色总共有三个颜色姐妹们啊
喜欢的姐姐一口原来是69块的啊
原来是69块的
人棉尼龙锯纸的
人棉尼龙锯纸的来黑色给你们看一下
还有黑色
看看还有一个黑色黑色的
看看面料嘎嘎舒服啊
穿在身上有弹力的这种穿的舒服
要黑色的49扣个5
要黑色的49去扣个5
来这个白色的纱裙
一层一层的一层一层一层的啊
来腰式松紧腰
来看一下这个蛋糕裙白色白色蕾丝的啊
纱的腰围66可以拉伸到66可以拉伸到82
腰围66可以拉伸到82
臀围126可以拉到132
裙长来90裙长90
来这个裙子谁要59 59扣个7
59扣7姐妹们装啊
59 59谁要谁来扣个7
谁要谁来扣个7呀
还有一个这个黑色的这个纱裙
这个有有白有黑啊
有白有黑腰也是半腰松紧的
也是一层一层的
面料丝滑的很啊
面料丝滑的很
来这一款腰围的话是64
可以拉伸到82
64 82
来臀围的话是130
臀围130
平常的话是90
来这个59 59扣个8
59扣8
来喜欢的姐妹直接就扣59
扣8扣8
扣9扣9扣 vocês
皮卡扎 citadel
扬星
圣经
邮箱
algo
这个衣服
月
在 zas
袋
kap'mayt
我这 J
这个衣服我都没有见过
看到赚钱
应该 outset
废 进
simultaneous
那个苹果气泡
在不在
明明回我了
来这一款来给宝宝看
38码码
人年80
尼龙12
巨值8%
他说不知道不知道
你备注号如果备注上了
他就给你发了
你备注热号如果没备注上
就没有发
他是根据备注号发过的
所以你有没有备注
你看你有没有备注
备注了那就发了
他这样说的
没收到
那你等下一个
再没收到的话
你再找好吧
再找我们
他一直要回我
我一直要回
我这样学给你啊
来这一款
戴帽子的戴帽子的
这个位移
哇塞这个面料
这个绝对是高货
绝对是高货
这个牌
这个牌子
他说他不知道
对
他说不知道不知道
他说是
如果备注备注上
然后他就这样说的
不知道不知道
如果备注上了
我就给他发了
如果备注号没备注上
那就没有发
他说我是根据备注号发的
就这样说的
来这个牌
这个牌子
人年尼龙加巨值的
哇面料舒服的很
面料舒服的很
然后他秀的上这里有一块色差
有一块就是脏了
咱们回家泡一泡洗一洗
那这个衣服我来量一下
面料超好
他这个后背很有特色的
来胸尾的话是126130
长度的话是65
好嘞好嘞
我知道了
我给他说了
来这一款谁要谁来扣他
他发货老搞错
揍他
真的揍他现在后面底边开着那个是松紧的
来这个衣服你们谁要我不管啥价了
我也不知道这不懂这个牌子
反正摸着面料是很好
但是他袖子上有一块色差吗
对不对
那这一款的话我就给你们放福利啊
29你们谁要这一股
这里还有点脏
有这里
这里是脏的
这里是脏的看到了吗
来谁要2929扣个二
2929扣个二
而面料超舒服
面料超舒服的啊
2929谁要谁来扣个二扣个二扣个二
来喜欢的姐姐就给我29扣个二
上面写的是M码38的
我给你量一下
超舒服超舒服
胸围的话是130长度的话是65长度65胸围130
他是一个38的M码
看看他水洗标上写的
然后写的是人棉80尼龙12
锯纸8%看38码
M的
超级好
这个就给咱们那个199的面料是一样的啊
摸着就是那么软
啊你看看
这是一个卫衣大的面料
超级舒服
我不知道卖多少钱
我也不认识这个牌子
反正我看脏了对吧
所以就给你们
放福利了OK
先放一边
我感觉那里啊
秀的那里可能是个油
我刚刚往底下放的时候
闻到一股那个油的味道啊
实话实说
回家用洗洁精给他泡一泡
搞不好就泡掉了
来这个圆领圆领啊
哎来这个牌子啊
这个牌子这个牌子SRR的来这款后面有刺绣字母
有刺绣字母有胶衣字母
是刺绣字母
这个是全棉的啊
原来都是要卖39的
原来卖39的
均码哦不是全棉
棉35聚质65
棉35聚质65来胸围
胸围106110106110长度前面68后面73来这款谁要1919扣1
谁要谁来过19扣1
这个男生穿男生穿这个T可以的啊
底下有弧度的底下有弧度男女都可以穿的男生女生都可以穿啊
这个我也得放一放
OKOK好
来这个羊羔毛的这个马甲这个马甲软的很哦
软的很超软超软超软有拉链两边有口袋的两边和他之前到好多
但是都卖完了
这种胸围106110106110长度71来这一款谁要2929扣个二
看看羊羔毛羊羔毛谁要谁来扣29扣2天冷的时候穿嘎嘎舒服
看里边也是毛的超软超软啊
29扣个二
29谁要谁来扣个二羊羔毛羊羔毛的这个马甲咱们可以就是说天哎哟一看一来看到这个这个马甲你还记得不原来好像是59的吧
这马甲之前有好多
但是卖完了来这个马甲里边羊羔毛外面羊羔毛前面有拉链的两边有口袋两边有口袋啊
这个羊羔毛的2929哎呦嘛
年一百
全棉一百的啊
29谁要谁来扣个二天冷的时候把它穿到里边保暖
来胸围的话是106长度的话是72来2929扣2扣2
来喜欢的姐姐就扣29扣个二你刚刚忙好呀
啥
喜标写的是全棉棉一百的没错
没错
哎呦嘛
年一百年一百
他写的是全棉的
写的是全棉
今天你那边多少度啊
下雨了没昨天
下雨了没
对啊
他写的是全棉
但是很软
咱不知道啥面料
等风来
昨天不是刮风了吗
来这个裙子来个忙看啊
这些款我都没有看到过来这个裙子
这个裙子这个裙子来这款上面是个黄色底下是个卡其色啊
后面看一下领口后面是有拉链的领口后面是有拉链的
昨天是强对流
那你这两年应该气温没那么高
这个应该是全棉的
但他没有标了
我摸着这个就是全棉
来这一款咱们来量一下
另一个包应该到了
我就看看好的好了
你去看看
胸围一百一百零六一百一百零六腰围一百一百零四腰围一百一百零四群长八十